hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best simply because we
said so that's how this works if we say
so it is this is the business show that
my brothers and i wish that we had when
we were learning about business
investing in finance i am here with two
of my brothers joe and john how do you
know their names are joe and john well
simple their names are on the back of
their chairs great weekend john flew
back last night he was johnny jett said
johnny was not going to miss a show ever
iron man you good what is this 74 yeah
you're good voice a little raspy but
yeah yeah you went to the giants game
yesterday they won so yeah you're good
luck we're gonna send you the next thing
because as long as you keep showing up
at one point the score was five to three
i thought i was watching baseball so i
was a little confused but since you were
there i appreciate you going because
you're obviously the good luck charm so
it's perfect joe are you good i'm yeah
i'm great yeah ranger owes me money no
problem
you don't know you should
no ranger definitely owes me money uh
all right before we get started today
though i want to address a controversy
that's been going on on this show joe
and john have tried to start a union try
it
what do you mean tried it's already
happening they forgot who they were
messing with they forgot that they were
messing with the gepetto of the internet
so youtube fools
i have a message for you and i think
we're gonna play it right now you're
going off script i have no idea what
you're doing but i don't don't worry i
think we're gonna play the video right
now i got a little message for the best
business uh show was teaching everyone
about investing hey give the best
business show hey shout out to the best
business show and we're not joining the
union and i want to wish everyone good
luck and making about cash y'all keep
going man go down with the cash man hey
shout out to the business uh show yeah
and do not join the union
don't [ __ ] with me
do not mess with me
you all ain't ready for the island boys
the island boys are the island boys are
part of the union busters don't be
messing with us oh my god
i'm coming in with this
that was pretty good get out of here
look at youtube
don't be messing with me you almost
forgot who you're messing with get the
hell out of you
all right that was pretty good
john and i are going to allocate some
union dues to uh you're figuring out
you're not topping that one you're not
see the island boys real quick turn
around and shout out to the island boys
don't join the union you got john crying
over there
you good john very unexpected yeah
listen you guys thought that the union
was up to them this is where you
you guys thought that this was gonna be
unencumbered i'm coming out with meme
warfare all right that was pretty good
that's either one of you two are getting
anything done around this this battle is
uh it's to be continued we'll be back
don't worry the union doesn't go down
that easy to in the union
listen they own the internet right now
nobody's better on the internet than
those two right now all right now that
we got that out of the way by the way
people are saying wow the union is dead
you ain't dead the members of the island
john is still laughing he's still shook
by that was a good one
western union's the only thing dying on
this show by the way
we're giving out all kinds of stuff
today start smashing the like button
when we cross over 500 likes we're gonna
give away a hundred dollars in free
bitcoin to start the week contents free
that means that you come here you just
smash the like button that's the entry
fee we'll give out a hundred dollars
worth of bitcoin right now live on the
show john will pick it rest in peace the
union they see it in the chat it's over
uh on top of that when we get to a
thousand likes we're not gonna give away
money we have an item that we're gonna
give away we all sat around figured out
something that we're gonna give away a
physical item it's pretty damn good
john's excited about it is this the best
thing we're going to give away no i mean
we've given away a lot of stuff tvs
yeah money
let's get the 500 likes on the count of
three one two three everyone smash the
like button we'll give away a hundred
dollars worth of bitcoin right now
all you have to do to
be entered is just drop your twitter
account or your instagram handle in the
chat john's gonna pick one person after
we get done with the first topic uh and
we will go ahead and get you a hundred
dollars with a bitcoin start the week
nice little uh monday morning wake me up
i can't believe you've paid the island
just to disrupt the union
hey listen you know sometimes you don't
you don't do the work yourself you just
bring in the big guns
i'm pumped that they're on cameo making
cash already they're like dude we're
famous right now let's go for it are you
shook right capitalized no i'm good i'm
gonna get you back you're good all right
no problem uh uh don't forget sofi.com
make sure that you go there uh when you
go to sofi.com tomorrow we have the very
first diamond hands club event if you
listen to us last week and you got your
account created you got your two
thousand dollars in there an investing
account you're going to get an invite to
come to the diamond hands club tomorrow
what that means is that me joe john we
are all going to sit down we're going to
get on zoom with you we're going to talk
about investing we're going to share
some of the information that we've
learned over time we're also going to
answer questions et cetera if you want
to join the diamond hands club there are
going to be periodic events i don't know
if it's going to be exactly weekly or
every other week but you're going to
want to be in here so go to sofi.com
open up an account get two thousand
dollars in there either deposit two
thousand or grow your account to two
thousand dollars and then you get into
the diamond hands club pretty damn
simple keep smashing the like button
when we get to a thousand likes we're
gonna give away the physical item and
yes the bestbusiness show.com make sure
that you go there the sale is over no
more 21 off but everything that we're
wearing minus my sweatshirt is in the
store so go there bestbusinessshow.com
all right
friday night jack dorsey sent the tweet
heard round the world he explicitly went
out and said the one word that people in
the developing nations always shy away
from he tweeted and said hyperinflation
is going to change everything it's
happening
now jack dorsey is not just an average
person on twitter he's the founder and
ceo of the business he also is the
founder and ceo of square 100 billion
dollar financial firm and so for him to
utter the words inflation hyperinflation
people get real uncomfortable but
let's dig into exactly what he's talking
about so in the replies we saw somebody
say yep we live with this built into our
mental models in nigeria inflation is
currently 16
in nigeria and jack said it will happen
in the united states soon and so the
world he's specifically referring to the
fact that the united states dollar is
global reserve currency
then somebody said hyperinflation is a
currency collapse worst possible outcome
for most be careful what you wish for
and jack says not a wish nor do i think
it's a positive at all so jack's
obviously very clear one in
understanding what inflation is what
hyperinflation is two that it's bad that
we shouldn't wish for it and also
understand that there's other places
around the world that have high levels
of inflation and he is basically saying
that it's starting to happen here in the
united states now as you would expect
all of the
mainstream puppets they just came
running out of the woodwork oh look it's
a tech pro he tweeted about
hyperinflation what does he know let's
just go dunk on them and so here's a
couple of people who i think their
tweets won't necessarily end up
very well idiots literally run
everything yes jack dorsey the one of
the best entrepreneurs of our lifetime
who has built two multi-billion dollar
companies is an idiot correct great job
vincent then if we look at robin's
wigglesworth literally one of the
absolute worst mainstream financial
analysts and reporters when it comes to
any of this stuff said strong contender
for macro tourist of the century gong
well jack dorsey probably understands
this stuff better than robin and then we
have david larder who says
hyperinflation is not happening put the
bong down
right and then we also have oliver
rennick who probably well i'm not going
to say it but
it works at td ameritrade as a
journalist and uh is questionable at
best so nice to see jack finally out
himself as a huckster
okay
uh then we have virginia this was the
grand champion the person who by far had
the absolute best uh stupid tweet said
like divorce in a marriage this word
jack tweeted should not be uttered
unless you're trying to bring it into
being no one should take investment
advice from someone who sees himself as
making markets how insanely reckless to
tweet this immoral jack ban thyself
so literally the mainstream puppets all
calling for the censorship of jack
dorsey because he said hyperinflation is
going to change everything and it's
happening but virginia of course she
couldn't take the crown steve hanke who
is undefeated in stupid takes he decided
to come over the top off the top rope
360 windmill dunk there have been 62
certified hyperinflations in world
history at present no countries
experiencing hyperinflation jack should
know better than to tweet irresponsible
public statements now what steve is
specifically referring to is the exact
definition
of hyperinflation is 50
month-over-month inflation that
qualifies as hyperinflation so if you're
at 48 month-over-month inflation you
don't count as hyperinflation but if
you're at 50 it counts it doesn't matter
how bad the situation is it doesn't
matter if people on the ground can't
afford food if they're willing to take
to the streets in protest in an attempt
to overthrow a central bank or a
government like we see happening in the
last couple of weeks and multiple places
around the world that doesn't count as
hyperinflation because steve henke said
it doesn't meet
50 percent month-over-month inflation so
the measurement of hyperinflation is
stupid because some academics just came
up with a random number back in a
classroom somewhere and they said this
is the only way that it categorizes as
hyperinflation but ultimately
hyperinflation when people refer to that
what they are referring to is run away
high inflation if you live in a country
that has 10 percent month over month in
fl inflation you're trying to leave
you're out you're trying to escape that
is a really bad situation whether it is
10 month over month or 50
it's really bad i would argue even two
or three percent month over month
inflation is really bad and you would be
trying to escape and so of course
michael saylor the adult in the room
stepped in and said inflation is the
problem bitcoin is the solution
now when we start to actually look at
this let's first start with what exactly
are the official numbers the numbers
that all of the mainstream puppets all
point to and say oh look we don't have
hyperinflation we just have 5.4
inflation so first we can look at the
federal reserve's money supply the m2
absolute rocket ship up and to the right
no end in sight they can't stop they
can't bring it down literally we are
just going to go off like a rocket ship
then when we look at price inflation for
all items since 1913 what we see
is that it appears like inflation has
actually come down over time it's gotten
better congratulations amazing well as
with most things in the world it's not
because you're comparing apples to
apples they keep changing the definition
of the cpi inflation they literally are
manipulating the data in order to show
you a lower number and to trick people
into believing that the true inflation
number is not as high as it is don't
believe me this is a direct quote out of
an investopedia article that clearly
outlines exactly what the controversy is
originally the cpi was determined by
comparing the price of a fixed basket of
goods and services spanning two
different periods
in this case the cpi was a cost of goods
index so would look at what is the
change in the cost of these goods
however over time congress embraced the
view that cpi should reflect changes in
the cost to maintain a constant standard
of living so consequently the cpi has
evolved into a cost of living index it's
different than a cost of goods index
over the years the methodology used to
calculate the cpi has undergone numerous
revisions
according to the bls the changes removed
biases that cause the cpi to overstate
the inflation rate so the people who are
incentivized to have inflation lower
said oh we're overstating it and so
we're going to
remove bias and so we're going to change
the way that we count the new
methodology takes into account changes
in the quality of goods and substitution
substitution the change in purchases by
consumers in a response to price changes
changes the relative weighting of the
goods in the basket that ladies and
gentlemen is manipulation they're
literally switching things in and out in
an effort to show you a lower inflation
rate the overall result tends to be a
lower cpi exactly what we're talking
about however critics view the
methodological changes and the switch
from a cost of goods index to a cost of
living index as a purposeful
manipulation that allows the us
government to report a lower cpi
now this ultimately gets at the crux of
it if you remember in a
previous episode we talked about the
fact that the cpi rent index shows a two
percent
year-over-year change in rents
i dare one of you to go and find me
places in the united states where it is
less than two percent two percent is
supposed to be the national average of
the change in rent
that's not happening
actually zillow shows almost 9 or 10
change in rents apartment.com shows 13
or 14
change in rents year over year so how is
it that the private companies that have
points up to a hundred million data
points in real time are showing us
anywhere between eight to fourteen
percent change year over year but the
government statistics that are based on
the 1990 census data are telling us that
inflation is actually just under two
percent when it comes to rents it
doesn't make sense they don't have good
data sets and they don't have proper
methodology to actually calculate this
now that brings us back to jack dorsey
and twitter and square twitter has
nothing to do with inflation
nobody's claiming that jack dorsey as
ceo and founder of twitter knows
anything about inflation
but jack dorsey the co-founder and ceo
of square a hundred plus billion dollar
financial firm that may have the most
robust and accurate real-time data set
in the world on what the united states
inflation number is we should probably
be listening now what do i mean that
square has the most robust real-time
accurate data set well let's look at
square's product suite
square has a number of products that you
may not be aware of first they have the
reader where they are physical devices
that allow mobile phones to process
payments they then have square register
right at the point of sale for many
merchants they have virtual gift cards
they also have cash app which is a
consumer mobile app for banking services
and investing more than 30 million
monthly active users on cash app they
also have square capital which is
financing to merchants they have square
payroll literally they process the
payroll of multiple companies they have
square financial services which is a
bank charter they also have credit karma
tax which has been integrated into cash
app and then they just acquired after
pet which now is getting them into the
buy now pay later game with over a
hundred thousand merchants in various
countries
when you start to look at this square
not only sees the actual real time data
at the point of sale
what was this business at their register
selling this good for last year what are
they selling it for now there's no i
call them and ask them there's no i hope
they're reporting the right number it is
the absolute truth it's at the register
they literally own the data at the
register they know exactly what that
item or that sku was selling for last
year and they know what it is selling
now
on top of that they also have 30 million
monthly active users on cash app some of
that is just for peer-to-peer
transactions where they're sending money
back and forth to each other but also
they have about seven million people who
use the cash card it's literally a debit
card where they can see all of the
purchase data on top of that they have
square payroll where they can see hey
what was this employee being paid by
this company last year and what are they
being paid now there is no reporting
there is no i call and i ask there is no
waiting for your tax returns it is
real-time robust data set and so i don't
know what the data says but neither does
anybody else but if the ceo of a company
that is sitting on this specific data
set is telling us that there are higher
levels of inflation than what the
official numbers are reporting
rather than trying to dunk on him on the
internet and rather than trying to label
him an idiot or saying that he's simply
a macro tourist of the century maybe we
should listen
and that's the problem with discourse in
2021
is that it can't possibly be true in the
eyes of the establishment that actually
the guy who has a technology company who
sits on top of the most robust accurate
real-time data set probably in the
country
he possibly couldn't know what he's
talking about because the reporters they
believe that the cpi metric is real
because the government is coming to save
them
what do we think in terms of watching
the reaction to jack's comments on this
the reaction's ridiculous right like
it's one of the uh the most annoying
parts of uh of social media and twitter
specifically sometimes is that someone
can say something that isn't a consensus
thought and all the people with large
audiences basically go retweet that
tweet and dunk on them uh to whether
it's for likes or kind of getting their
opinion out there but this is clearly
one of those cases where jack said
something that's against the grain but
when you think about it not only does he
have this large data set but it's not
like anyone in this country would uh
assume hyperinflation is coming before
it got here right like it's obviously a
thought that wouldn't be carried by most
especially economists today so i think
when anyone that not only has a company
like square and has all this data and
everything else but someone who's
clearly uh intellectual about this kind
of stuff and i spent a lot of time not
only studying digital assets like
bitcoin but economics uh specifically i
think it's something that you clearly
need to pay attention to and as we know
like most of the uh kind of the most
outside thinkers uh that are intelligent
people are actually right about a lot of
these things whether it's kind of
economics or technology or anything else
and i think when it comes to inflation
we obviously have some inflation right
it's just a measure so if it's 10 15 25
50 there's a difference but we don't
need to get to hyperinflation for it to
be a big deal right we could get to 20
25 it's a massive deal so i think uh
there's a lot of things that can can
change right like the supply chain is
obviously things that one thing that
people are worried about people believe
that artificial intelligence is going to
reduce things over time and it's going
to help aid the money supply that's
coming in there's a bunch of kind of
nuance to it but i think ultimately just
the general idea that people are going
to [ __ ] on jack dorsey for this is
stupid john what do you think um i think
virginia's bro are you good i'm good i'm
good give him get him one get one
i think virginia's comments are a little
reckless like trying to tell someone
that they can't utter a word because it
may bring it into existence is dumb you
have to talk about things in advance
especially before they get there jerome
powell said on friday inflationary
pressures are going to continue into
next year right there's no sign of them
slowing down but inflation is transitory
as he keeps saying says him um and
the rate for hyperinflation should not
be 50 in my mind if you want to count
someone's hyper for hyperinflation it
would probably be around 30 percent
30 year-over-year or 30 month over month
30 year-over-year yeah
so basically this is a key difference is
what they're talking about is 50
monthly inflation which is over 11 000
percent like literally they say
venezuela doesn't have hyperinflation
zimbabwe not hyperinflation lebanon not
hyperinflation like we can go around the
world in all these countries where
literally people are starving they are
out in the street attacking central
banks attacking their governments and
yelling and screaming about it and those
don't count as hyperinflation because
it's not 11 000
annual inflation right i think your
point is just it should be something
much lower the bar for hyperinflation
should be much lower but regardless of
the semantics of it your point here is
that the you think that the numbers are
higher than the official numbers agreed
and i think bitcoin solves it as well
do we think that anyone at the fed or
the treasury actually believes the
official numbers are the real numbers no
i i think uh i think jack dorsey has
better data than they do
of course he does yeah
one of the points that i made over the
problem sorry real quick the problem for
me would be if he understands the what's
kind of contributing to those factors
right if you look at the numbers you say
okay this good at this store cost x more
than it did last year at the same time
great that's a good number to have but
ultimately you need to understand the
inputs of those right and understand
whether it's supply chain or kind of the
money supply or whatever it is why it's
impacting that so the real key is yeah
he has great data is he analyzing it
correct is the question i think the the
key to this i think is uh square has a
multi-dimensional view of the economy
they see what people are being paid they
see what the actual point of sale data
is they see what the individuals are
doing whether it's on the cash app the
card et cetera they have a 360 view of
what's happening in the actual uh
economy now there's some people who
would say the critique of that is there
may be some industries where they don't
have data right and and that may be true
fine but they still have the most robust
set it's not about having the perfect
data set it's about who has a better
data set and then on top of that how do
you actually calculate what is the
inflation rate right so if you start to
do things where you basically are trying
to estimate what should the weightings
of the various assets in a basket be
they're going to ultimately be incorrect
there's no way to know there's no right
answer and so instead just looking at a
cost of goods index and going back to
the way that inflation used to be
measured i think is a more accurate way
to actually get a sense for what is the
inflation rate you can also look at it
as okay let's use the proxy of asset
inflation
assets are up 30 percent in the stock
market year over year right bitcoin's up
400 percent real estate in many markets
is up 15 20
and so if you're gonna tell me that the
food didn't go up in price but all of
the assets did that doesn't that is
there's no kind of uh way to kind of
settle that out right if you get asset
appreciation guess what some of the
other assets are going to go up in price
too they just have to be consumption
assets right food or gasoline or
whatever these things are and so i think
that's one key piece to it the second
piece is your point around
why this is happening is a whole
different issue right you can make an
argument and i think that there's
there's plenty of weight to put on that
inflation is happening because there's
supply chain disruptions right and that
could be kind of an elementary view and
say hey as long as there's going to be
supply chain disruptions there's going
to be high inflation a second order of
that argument would be hey we handed out
free money to a bunch of people and we
started to devalue the currency which
financially incentivized people to get
out of cash and spend it and so what
they ended up doing was they went and
they started spending egregiously and as
they started to spend egregiously that
drastically increased demand on these
supply chains they weren't ready for the
demand so the supply chain started to
break because of the increase in demand
that was driven by the monetary and
fiscal policy right and therefore now we
have high inflation because you take the
monetary and fiscal policy combine it
with supply chain disruptions and
therefore you get high inflation i don't
think it's either or right absolutely
there's supply chain disruptions but
also there's monetary and fiscal policy
that's absolutely absurd as well and so
when you start to put all this together
the ultimate question is just
why do we continue to make decisions
based on a belief that inflation on a
cpi basis is five point four percent and
on a core basis is four percent
if we know that those numbers aren't
right because there's people with better
data sets who are telling us that and
also we know that the uh chairman
federer of the federal reserve has
explicitly stated the unofficial numbers
the second that all of a sudden they
talk about the unofficial numbers i want
to know why are those unofficial and
these are official right but those are
higher
and so it almost feels like there's like
a little bit of a charade here and i
think ultimately the key is nobody wants
to live through high inflation nobody
right whether you're uh an elite or
you're somebody who has no assets nobody
wants to live through that even though
the elites end up actually owning assets
and those asset prices go up and they
quote unquote get richer ultimately what
we have seen time and time again is that
once it starts there's no turning back
and they end up getting screwed as well
and they ultimately have to go somewhere
else right they have to get out of that
regime they have to go somewhere else
and i think that most people in the
united states believe the united states
is still the leader on a global stage
and in order to continue that we have to
have a good economic situation and
people have to believe that they can
come here to this country and they can
build a life of financial security right
and so
if we're now looking at a data set that
again
even if it was just 10 inflation there's
a big difference between 5.4 inflation
and 10 percent and so the question is
just like how high is the actual
inflation number and
somehow cpi is never is stated higher
than what the estimates are i've never
seen the official numbers come in more
than people think it is yeah it's always
the reverse and that tends to be the
problem in my opinion yeah i was
actually kind of surprised at surprised
partially but also not surprised that
how many people kind of came in and
crashed in on him right because
ultimately what a lot of these people
are doing is they're just kind they're
they're propagating the idea that the
government is here to save people and
that's not what the case is right
everyone is scared of hyperinflation no
one wants that no one wants to live
through that but the idea that it could
happen is not out of the realm of
possibility so people completely
dismissing it on twitter doesn't make a
lot of sense and i think secondly the
general idea we didn't show
any specific tweet of it but i saw
multiple times people were dunking on
him popular people with large accounts
were dunking on him and basically saying
uh jack just is doing this for bitcoin
right he owns a lot of bitcoin
hyperinflation would be good for bitcoin
jack stands the profit off of this
that's idiotic right the guy's worth 15
billion dollars he donated a billion
dollars last year and he's tracking it
on google doc right like
which is insane to the top of his
twitter account yeah like hey go see
what i'm spending the money on if you
got a problem with it right i donated a
billion dollars so the idea that he owns
bitcoin to prop it up to profit off
hyperinflation in the u.s is idiotic in
my opinion and he shouldn't be uh kind
of reprimanded for sounding the alarm to
some sense on twitter to average
american citizens
john what would you do if you were uh in
his shoes
jack's shoes
yeah would you open source the data
oh for square yeah
yeah i mean look
one thing i think that will help is
getting as many
qualified people's eyes on a certain
data set to help figure out what the
actual number is right because it
depends on how he's analyzing the data
right so i think the government should
do that as well and kind of put all
their data that they get into a um into
an open source system where people can
go in and analyze it how they see fit
and then i guarantee we'll get we'll get
inflation numbers all the way up to 60
percent
and we'll have people saying that it's
negative and there's actually no
inflation right because you can
manipulate the numbers in so many
different ways correct you guys want to
see uh the absolute most absurd article
that i saw written over the weekend
yeah this one
this was in the atlantic and the title
is stop shopping
and literally it came with a tweet that
said supply chain problems could be
solved more quickly if affluent
americans would stop buying up things
they don't need and often don't even
really want
so literally stop spending rather than
fix our monetary and fiscal policy or
rather than actually make more redundant
resistant uh and resilient uh supply
chains stop shopping
so they're taking the other maybe it's
easier for us to just tell people to
stop buying things like what yeah what
is going on right now if you hand people
free cash they're going to go and spend
it of course if you manipulate the
currency and devalue it at a historic
rate they're going to go spend it
they're not morons you know what's going
to be interesting is uh with everything
going on in the supply chain so i read
something it was a week or two ago at
this point which basically said that if
your stuff hadn't shipped if a brand
hadn't shipped product already for
christmas it wasn't going to get here in
time right because if you think about
how long it normally takes i think nike
said it takes him usually around 40 days
to ship things from asia to the u.s here
in california or kind of one of the
eastern ports right so 40 days it's now
about 80 days so twice as long we're 60
or whatever days 65 70 days outside of
christmas so if it hasn't already been
shipped it's not going to be here in
time we're going to be at a record low
inventory when it comes to christmas
shopping it's going to be interesting to
see what that happens in the digital
space right whether
uh gift cards or nfts or bitcoin right
people start giving these digital gifts
rather than physical things that they
couldn't go out and purchase themselves
oh give give the gifts of give the gift
of assets for christmas y'all can buy me
bitcoin yeah christmas i'll take some
bitcoin i'll get the island boys to send
you something
thank god [ __ ] john do you have a
winner from the giveaway earlier yeah
who you got it is somebody's about to
win a hundred dollars with a bitcoin
justin platt congratulations justin
platt you win
100 bucks
you got a twitter account yeah all right
we're in business justin there you go on
the count of three hit the like button
we're gonna give away the first product
ready one two three smash the like
button and we cross over uh oh we
already crossed over a thousand ready
should we should we first enter people
to win or should we tell them what the
gift is first enter first no no tell
them what the gift is so we you know
yeah
you don't want it stay out of here
listen we live in stressful times all
right we live in times where you might
not be looking at your portfolio every
day because you're stressed out somebody
may be yelling at you at your house you
may go on the internet and have a bad
day and so we don't want you all to be
maybe you're squatting 500 pounds i
don't know yeah maybe 500 pounds maybe
you just need to relax a little bit so
we're gonna give one person a brand new
massage gun
[Laughter]
that's just a cool gift that john thinks
this is the coolest gift that we've ever
offered somebody so we're gonna give out
a massage gun right now live
gave a 50-inch screen tv now we're gonna
give out a massage gun ready on the
count of three drop your twitter account
and also what you did this weekend
twitter account what you did this
weekend one person is gonna get a
massage gun deep tissue deep tissue
massage gun fusion black pro muscle
massage gun deep tissue percussion
muscle massage people are in the
comments saying hey mateo if you're
listening to this i need a new mattress
we may we may have to somebody said i'm
literally in the gym right now drop your
twitter account and also what'd you do
this weekend joe's going to pick one
person we're going to give this thing's
on sale too you're getting it we're
getting we're getting on sale we are
getting on sale perfect somebody said yo
i got one that works
products approved all right we'll come
back joe's gonna pick a winner and we'll
come back to it
over the weekend the treasury secretary
decided to go ahead and have a video
come out where they talk about taxing
unrealized gains before we talk about
this i just want to play the video and
allow you to see directly from her mouth
what she's talking about but this is
treasury secretary janet yellen's
comments on unrealized gains being taxed
and we are going to also explain in a
second
why this makes zero sense not only could
they possibly not implement it but on
top of that there is a very low
likelihood that they would actually be
able to enforce it it makes no sense to
do but it also makes no sense in terms
of how they would try to enforce it in
any way
give us one second we're going to pull
it up here in in a second john when uh
we picked the winner by the way
that uh senator wyden and the senate
finance committee have been looking at
that would
impose
attacks on unrealized capital gains
on liquid assets held by extremely
wealthy individuals billionaires
i wouldn't call that a wealth tax but
it would help get at capital gains which
are an extraordinarily large part of the
incomes of the wealthiest individuals
and
right now
escape taxation
until they're realized and often they're
unrealized and that death uh benefit
from a so-called step up of basis so
it's not a wealth tax but um a tax on
unrealized capital gains of
exceptionally wealthy individuals
what
[Music]
is going on
it's not a wealth tax
but we're only going to tax the wealthy
this
is the classic massaging of words and
playing with nomenclature and vernacular
that just makes zero sense
what they are talking about in terms of
taxing unrealized gains is if i was to
buy a stock let's say with a hundred
dollars and that hundred dollars then
went up to five hundred dollars i would
have four hundred dollars worth of
unrealized gain hundred dollars of
principal four hundred dollars of gain
but i haven't yet sold this stock
so i don't actually have cash yet and
until i sell the stock the government
doesn't tax me in the current form the
current regime
what they are talking about here is
saying well
if your stock goes up every year
we're going to tax you
which means that they would ask me out
of that 400 let's say that my tax rate
was 25
to pay them 100 of taxes
so i either would have to have a hundred
dollars somewhere else to go ahead and
pay them their taxes or i would have to
sell the asset
in order to raise the capital to get the
hundred dollars to pay the tax
now
the first thing that i think is the
problem
is that
when you start to talk about we're we're
only going to do this to the
billionaires we're only going to do this
to the richest people we're only going
to do this to the people that we've now
tried to condemn success
people will cheer them on but it's the
people who frankly don't really get it
because just like everything first it
starts with the billionaires then it
starts with 100 millionaires then it
starts with the millionaires and then it
starts with the thousand airs and
eventually everyone is taxed with
unrealized capital gains
but ultimately if you're a first
principles thinker you begin to realize
they are trying to do this to pay for a
bill that they continue to tell us costs
zero dollars
well obviously it doesn't cost zero
dollars if you have to take
money from other people in order to pay
for it
it's not that it costs zero dollars it's
that you're trying to get other people
to pay for it instead of the government
and so when you start to look at this
entire situation i do not believe it
will get passed i do not believe that
this is even within the realm of
possibility
but it's a very scary situation
because if they were able to start with
billionaires and then move their way
down
are they eventually going to ask people
hey your house went up 25 over the last
year
you need to pay us taxes on that 25 gain
you had a house that was worth a hundred
grand it's now worth 125 000
well you owe us 10 grand for taxes pay
up big dog
no of course not but it's also
unreasonable for what are they going to
ask is elon musk and jack dorsey and
jeff bezos and a plethora of other
people who have built the country's most
successful companies that employ
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people collectively are we going to ask
them really to sell their stock every
year in order to pay the government
sounds like confiscation to me
you can wrap it in a bow you can call it
a tax you can even say that it's not a
wealth tax
but what you're doing is you're
explicitly targeting the successful
people and you're trying to take
something that they have that currently
today they are not doing anything wrong
because you want them to pay
for your undisciplined spending
this wouldn't even be a conversation if
we weren't trying to spend trillions of
dollars
on who knows what
the last infrastructure bill literally
the government wanted the authority to
buy weed to test whether there's an
impact on driving high
we got people on the show that'll do it
for free facts
and so when you start to understand how
insane this is you already kind of walk
away and you just say man we've entered
a weird world where this is actually
even being discussed as as a legit
proposal
but
if you start to think about
what is a realized gain
well first
one of the big things is
actually asset prices going up
is a unrealized loss
what do i mean
if i hold dollars over the last 18
months
i would have lost significant purchasing
power
approximately 40 percent of all dollars
in circulation were printed or created
in the last 18 months
and if that's the case my purchasing
power would have gone down i would have
lost
purchasing power
and so by not sitting in dollars and
instead investing in assets
i was able to avoid
losses
there was unrealized losses
now the fact that the assets went up in
price
that made me a bad person that make
anybody else a bad person it simply
means that i know that the currency in
which the asset is denominated in is
going to continue to lose value
and so ultimately what this type of
asset would do or this asset taxation
strategy would do
is it would disincentivize people from
investing it would force them or attempt
to force them to stay in the currency
and to be guaranteed to lose value
so ultimately what you get
is you get a lose-lose situation if
you're an individual you can sit in the
currency if you sit in the currency
you're guaranteed to lose purchasing
power right now you're losing it at a
historic rate and you're also guaranteed
to lose if you invest because they're
going to increase taxation on you
it doesn't make a lot of sense
now
i like to have fun on the internet so
yesterday i tweeted one bitcoin equals
one bitcoin so there are no unrealized
gains
just one bitcoin
it's a currency my currency didn't go up
or down in value your currency did
your currency devalued against mine
but i didn't have any gains i'd have any
losses
i just have one bitcoin that equals one
bitcoin
so how then do we calculate unrealized
gains or losses
well that's a good question on top of
that we have leo pulvitz who had a great
point he said disgusting proposal and
leo isn't necessarily somebody who
normally has any sort of bombastic
thoughts or opinions or tweets so
obviously he feels pretty strongly about
it he said one this penalizes builders
it's hard it's a net bad to force bezos
musk etcetera to sell their stock to
fund wasteful bureaucratic policies
that's right we want the builders the
founders the entrepreneurs the people
who have built the world's most
successful companies the problem solvers
the innovators we want to take capital
out of their hands we want to give it to
the government that make a lot of sense
the dot-com bubble showed dangers of
taxing unrealized gains and three this
would apply to liquid assets people will
just create workarounds because here
ultimately ends up being the best thing
i can tell you
is if they pass this it'll sound great
they would all get cheered on amazing
let's go after those evil billionaire
people
well
most of the billionaires they get paid
like 100 grand a year in income they're
going to take their assets they'll put
it in a trust or some other vehicle
they'll then say i don't own it and
therefore you can't tax me and they'll
just work right around it it'll be
another stupid obstacle in the way and
so even though the spirit of what
they're trying to accomplish in their
eyes is actually legitimate
and others disagree
they still won't get the intended impact
because you ultimately are not going to
be able to stop people from finding a
way around the rules
instead one of the first things that we
should do is maybe we should actually
balance the budget
there is no business in the world that's
able to spend more than they make every
single year in perpetuity
and for those people who continue to say
that the debt doesn't matter well it
does matter because the second you get
into trying to service the debt
then you start to box yourself in the
central bank doesn't have all the tools
in their toolbox they may not be able to
raise interest rates to slow the taper
or to actually create tapering or slow
any sort of monetary and fiscal stimulus
because then the servicing of debt
becomes questionable
and so ultimately what we are watching
right now
is that we're in a really weird
situation i don't know if there's a
right answer but what i do know is that
america was built on ethos of personal
freedom of individual liberties and we
should not discriminate on anyone for
wealth but that goes both ways the same
way that we shouldn't be taxing
billionaires with a wealth tax with it
which is exactly what this is
we also shouldn't be discriminating
against people who are not wealthy by
not allowing them to participate in
private market investing
in both cases you are discriminating
based on who is wealthy
in one case you're literally writing
into the rules and saying the rich get
richer only rich people are allowed to
invest in private market opportunities
that's wrong that's not what this
country was built on we should have an
education-based test
if you can pass the test you're educated
and therefore you can invest in whatever
you want take as much risk as you want
you're educated
but
we also shouldn't target the country's
richest people
simply because they're rich
in fact my guess is that if we started
to ask them hey
we want to solve this problem can you
pitch in
can you be
and contribute from a patriotic
standpoint to solving the problem
here's what we want to do
come help us
i actually bet a lot of them would pitch
in
and maybe it's financially maybe it's
not
but my guess is that actually their
financial contribution
wouldn't even be that big of a deal
if you took every dollar that jeff bezos
has to his name about 200 billion
dollars you can fund the federal
government
for less than a month
so what are you gonna do are you gonna
take the billionaire's wealth 12 of them
okay
now you don't even get the whole year
done
so what are you going to do
you can't just sit there and say it's a
revenue problem the u.s government has
taken in more federal tax income
every single year since the global
financial crisis every year they take in
more they have more revenue
yet the inter-year
deficit gets bigger and bigger
so the equivalent would be in year one i
take in a dollar but i spend two dollars
in year two i take in two dollars but
rather than spend the same two dollars
now i spend three dollars
then all of a sudden in year three i
take in three dollars of revenue but now
i spend five dollars and so actually
we've got a bigger deficit then in year
four i take in four dollars but now i
spend 10
then all of a sudden in year five i take
in five dollars and i spent 20 dollars
that is what is happening it is not a
revenue problem it is a spending problem
and until we can curtail spending
we will not solve many of these problems
we will not solve the taxation problem
we will not solve the inflation problem
we will not solve
a lot of these social issues that we
have
the wealth inequality gap in this
country is wider than it's ever been
and the reason is because the bottom 45
percent of americans hold cash and they
continue to be worse off year after year
after year
and it doesn't matter how much money you
take from the rich it doesn't matter
what else you do that is an extreme
measure until you stop hurting that
bottom 45 percent of americans
out of luck
what no i agree with all that i think uh
the part that's frustrating is that
people cheer this on right and people
see this as hey we're going after the
billionaires right and and there's a
point being made that yeah everyone
should pay their fair share of taxes
however you decide that should be done
and everyone should follow the rules but
ultimately this doesn't accomplish that
right the government is is essentially
hiding behind the idea that everyone's
going to rally around taxing
billionaires when on the other side of
it people aren't realizing right the
government created trillions and
trillions of dollars this year and like
you said drove the wealth inequality gap
to levels we haven't seen in over 50
years right they're spending hundreds of
millions of dollars to market the damn
lottery every year right like it's just
insane kind of how much the government
does on the other side of this to
continue to diminish the wealth of the
of the lower you know 30 40 50 percent
of this country that don't hold
investable assets so the idea that
taxing billionaires with this is going
to create uh is going to be a good thing
for the economy and for the lower class
of people is not correct they're doing
way more things on the backside of this
that are hurting people than would be
beneficial and i think when it comes
down to it like this isn't only the jeff
bezos of the world this isn't only the
elon musk of the world that this uh this
impacts right so if you think about a
startup founder right they take a
company they scale it up they build it
it's a billion two three billion dollar
company within three to four years are
they going to get taxed on the equity
that they own in that company now that
they haven't actually realized any of
that on paper they're worth a lot of
money on paper they're worth a billion
dollars they don't have that money in
their bank account right so now they're
gonna have to go sell shares in the
business they they created three or four
years ago that doesn't make much sense
to me so when you think about it in the
context of like how much sense it makes
when this came out i thought it was a
piece by the onion right
like literally that's how much that's
how funny it was the first time and now
we're two or three weeks later from the
initial mention of it and they're
serious about it they're literally
saying that they want to do this so uh
what started out as a joke has now
become a real
sort of a real possibility right like
probably doesn't get passed but at some
point they obviously think that it could
but i think i think the the everyday
person just needs to think about how
this impacts them long term right it
starts with a billionaire eventually
moves down everyone else next thing you
know we might begin tax for air they're
they're not going to give you unrealized
losses
if i buy an asset let's say i spent a
hundred dollars to buy a stock and the
stock goes down uh 25 so now i got 75 on
paper are they gonna give me a tax
credit for my 25 loss that even though i
didn't realize it of course not it's an
awful idea and to be honest i think they
will move down to you start with people
who have billion dollars and a million
dollars and all the way down and it's
going to be rocket fuel for the
inequality gap in this nation of course
on top of that uh i forget who said i
wish that i could remember i came here
if it was bitcoin tina or uh greg foss
uh they said oh shoot i just realized
everyone's going to be a billionaire
yeah everyone in the united states is
going to become a billionaire at some
point which is crazy that might be 200
years away
but everybody in zimbabwe is a
billionaire
right yeah when you start to think about
that
and maybe the the threshold isn't a
billion maybe it's a million right
whatever the actual rate at which there
is a currency devaluation
remember that in venezuela they took six
zeros
off the currency recently
so that means that now one bolivia
was a million boliviar
four weeks ago six weeks ago whatever it
was
so literally everyone was a millionaire
and now they just have one well and part
of it could be that they meet in the
middle right they say hey we're gonna
start at a billion and then it's 100
million or maybe it's 50 million or 10
million whatever it is and then that
that uh you know inflation or
depreciation of the dollar ends up
turning it the other way but ultimately
i think it's going to come on a lot more
people than they expect initially the
funny thing while all this is happening
the s p 500 just hit another all-time
high congratulations world record world
record smp has never been what it is i
got some smp that's good for me good job
johnny good job every four days i have
somebody on twitter i don't know if
they're comfortable with me saying who
they are but every time the s p 500 hits
an all-time high they dm me and say spy
all-time high and and they know that i'm
going to tweet it out so they're like
chat look like with him every day he's
enjoying every four days
uh so september first sp why all-time
high lol on it i mean we may talk daily
at this point he goes we are spy
all-time high best friends
the next day s p y all-time high 10
minutes ago
then uh he says i took my eyes off the
chart to make some coffee and what do
you know all-time high
sp y officially all-time high spy
all-time high like just over and over
and over and over again and so if you
think about that how can you tell me
that we are devaluing the currency we're
manipulating the market with interest
rates and quantitative easing and we're
driving asset prices up higher
but regular goods they're just up five
percent
stocks aren't
other assets aren't why is it that an
apple is only up five percent and
actually food is lower than the cpi in
many cases they're saying food's only
three or four percent okay
rent no fear it's only up two percent
i don't know where they're looking
i don't know where they're looking but
there's just no way there's just no
freaking way
john when you think about uh the stock
market going up have you changed asset
allocation at all or you you pretty much
have what you had at the beginning of
the year um
i mean i've gotten a little more uh like
spy and stuff like that but um i'm a
little weary that eventually like it's
almost like can't go up forever um
everyone is a genius in a bull market so
just remember that it can go up forever
it can go up forever that's true it will
go up forever yeah look i think long
term in 10 years it's obviously going to
appreciate a lot pornoid was picking
stocks out of a bag
he was right which is the funniest part
like literally they're just going up so
it doesn't matter well it's because the
value of the stocks is no longer being
determined exclusively by the value of
the business yeah right or i'm sorry the
price of the stock is no longer being
valued by the value of the business it
is now being a price that is determined
by a manipulated supply and demand
and the value of the business
there are literal [ __ ] coins trading in
the stock market right now that are
being propped up by insane monetary and
fiscal policy if you look at some of the
spac deals that have been approved and
are trading
it is
bonkers what is happening we're going to
talk about one of the specs here in a
second that uh
is uh pretty crazy um if we go and we
talk about speaking of elon musk i want
to talk about uh this idea that there
are now assets that trade based on who
the individuals are that are
believed to be supporting them and one
of those assets is shibu inu
already i'm out with the name but
recently
he was asked did he own any first
he said something to the effect uh not
explicitly talking about shibuya but he
said out of curiosity i have acquired
some aussie hash strings called bitcoin
ethereum and doge that's it as i've said
before don't bet the farm on crypto true
value is building products and providing
services to your fellow human beings not
money in any form and so ultimately elon
continues to explain why he doesn't look
at himself as an investor instead he
simply looks at himself as a builder as
an innovator and as an entrepreneur
but
earlier this year
elon was obviously tweeting a bunch
about many many different
cryptocurrencies and so he was asked by
shibu inu holder on twitter hey elon how
much shebe are you holding and he said
nothing
and when he said none jameson lop had a
great point jamison said if you live by
the meme you die by the meme lord
and so when all of a sudden people
believe that somebody like elon he's
going to buy it because he thinks it's
funny he's going to buy it because he
thinks it's going to go up well he's
actually being pretty rational he's
saying don't go bet the farm on one of
these assets
i will be the first one to say it and
people will get upset
but this stuff
it's entertainment it's not true
investing
and when you start to understand that
it's entertainment sure you want to go
by a little bit knock yourself out but
understand what you're doing it's no
different than going to a casino it's no
different than going and actually
sitting at a movie and watching
something it's no different than going
and joining a local club or a community
that's what this stuff is
there is value in various assets across
markets
but when you start to look at the meme
coins
there's plenty of other people who are
going to tell you it's going to the moon
it's going up etc but the one thing i
promise you guys is i'll always just
shoot you straight
i wouldn't buy this
the reason why i wouldn't buy it is
because ultimately what you are trading
on is you're trading on market dynamics
that have no ability to be rooted in
reality
you're literally watching an asset that
goes up and down based on speculation of
who may own it
now when you actually look at the
underlying fundamentals of it and you
look at developer activity and all the
things that would drive true value
it's just not there and again it's fun i
get it i see the memes i see the people
tweeting at me they're funny no problem
just don't go put
20
50
of your portfolio in this stuff
there's nothing wrong with making a
non-economic decision with half a
percent of your portfolio
whatever people do it all the time they
buy something because oh i shop there i
don't necessarily think the stocks can
go up but i shop there i like it i want
to support them sure
but do not confuse entertainment
and non-economic decision making with a
belief that something's going to go up
forever and that ultimately i think is a
lesson that has to be learned over and
over and over again
by people who come into the market
is that
yes in the short term things can be
irrational they can be illogical but
over a long period of time
value accrues to things that actually
have use
who actually have adoption and who
actually have developers that are
willing to build around and on top of it
and i don't expect this to be a popular
opinion everyone loves the idea of
participating in a market where there's
some level of everyone getting rich
but somebody's got to say it and so i
think that this is a great point by
jameson is if you live by the meme you
die by the meme lord
and
you just never know
when the death can come right guys
yeah i mean i'm not buying any of that
i
i think yeah you just need to be careful
like everyone likes to have fun even
when it comes to investing and these are
assets we'll call them that you can
invest in and have fun and it's a cool
community i'm sure and people are
enjoying it but ultimately you want to
put the large percentage of your
portfolio or the money that you're
trying to compound over time into assets
that you that you uh agree will
appreciate over time and and will bring
more value to the world and have real
you to utility and use cases and this
doesn't appear to be one so i think the
idea that you would buy an asset based
on who's supporting it or just kind of
the general thought behind and to be
fair i don't even know if elon said he
was ever supporting it maybe i'm wrong
on that but it seems like he never owned
any at any point and doesn't own
anything now you've got a picture of his
dog that looks like the sheba dog oh so
that's where it came from okay then
people started speculating yeah yeah
some people speculated again it's uh
it's not my my model to buy things that
uh yeah a celebrity maybe might be
interested in
another asset that has begun trading
that has taken the world by storm donald
trump has entered into an agreement for
a spac to buy the trump media and
technology group we'll get to that in a
second
but of course donald trump super
polarizing person lots of people love
him lots of people don't like them and
so the second that he is now able to
create an asset that trades on a public
stock market what do you think happens
of course it becomes the ultimate meme
stock and people rush in what we have
seen is that the trump spac which is
being technically acquired by the
digital world acquisition corp which
kind of sounds like prestige worldwide
dwac trades on the nasdaq
took off at the end of last week started
out at 10 bucks and it ran all the way
up over 150
15 x this thing exploded upwards
and now what's happened is as you see
that just
massive run-up and spike that was all
literally in about a two day period it's
come back down it's trading somewhere
around 90 to 100
and so quote unquote there's some level
of rationality kind of it's still up 9
to 10 x from where it started and so we
went deep deep deep deep
on the interwebs
and we're just going to pull up a couple
of slides from the trump media and
technology group deck
this gives softbank a run for its money
the trump media and technology group has
one mission
they will fight for the first amendment
protections and freedoms of all
americans protect democracy and defend
capitalism actually a pretty strong
mission i think most people would rally
around and say hey first amendment is
good democracy is good capitalism is
good they have their vision statement
there and we've got the next slide here
that shows that other freedoms are at
risk what happened to america's voice
and it talks about twitter banning a
president but maintaining a taliban
account which again a little crazy and
then if we go to the next slide
we can see this is where it gets a
little crazy the corporate competitive
structure we have truth social which by
the way is going to compete with twitter
and facebook
according to this deck
and this the social media platform is
called truth so you don't send a post
you don't send a tweet you send a truth
which is you know again i think a lot of
people look at it and say like oh wow
that's
that is a
very uh very unique way to approach it
they then have tmtg plus and tmtg news
which is supposed to compete with
streaming platforms like netflix and
disney or news organizations like cnn
and iheart media and then they have on
the far right here this dotted line
which is that there's a long-term
opportunity to actually build the tmtg
tech stack to go compete with aws google
cloud stripe and azure
pretty ambitious then we go the next
slide
we can see that
i don't know what this slide was
supposed to be for but it is a massive
market opportunity all of earth can fit
in the market opportunity uh
very very big market opportunity
obviously if we go to the next slide
we can see that they are trying to build
an inclusive big tent approach and what
they essentially are looking at here is
can they build tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of people to bring
both liberals independents and
conservatives all under one tent all are
welcome according to this slide go to
the next one
they're galvanizing a conservative media
universe
and so they have asteroids all coming
towards the tmtg earth
which i don't know if that's good or bad
actually now that i'm looking at it and
then if we go to the next one
what is tmtg plus they want to compete
with netflix disney and hulu they want
to basically have streaming news etc and
so when we start to think about this
what's our general thoughts on this
stock and uh kind of just going from you
know 10 bucks to 150 like is it
the biggest like duh we should have
predicted that it's a meme stock
i mean look the goal is great right if
you can build a company that encompasses
all those things bro they want to be the
best company in the world
like the goal i love it you're very
aspirational do i think that's going to
happen within the next 20 years no
that's the most beautiful deck ever the
most beautiful deck
did any of your friends buy it
no do you know of your friends about it
i'm not friends with idiots i
i know i know somebody who work i don't
want to say their name but they work at
a very well respected financial firm and
they told me that no somebody who sits
near them bought options on it and made
a ton of money on friday and he
basically was like dude what the hell
like you didn't tell me that the options
were priced at whatever and the whole
thing was he was just like yeah of
course like look at who's involved in
this of course it's gonna go up in price
like you know this is like literally the
meme stock of all meme stocks of course
they're gonna push it up and so i think
what you start to get is you get a bunch
of people uh that are trying to um make
money they're not necessarily buying it
because they believe there's gonna be
long-standing value with it what are you
laughing at no i mean i was laughing at
the comments people are just saying a
bunch of trump sayings
which are funny uh but yeah i think
options are one way to do it right if
you're basically just betting on the
volatility but i think and there's some
sort of it that people are betting and
buying the stock based on uh the idea
that it will become a mean stopper it'll
be popular but if you're buying this
stock under the assumption that it's
going to be worth x amount of money
based on the pitch deck that they gave
out i don't know if that's probably the
best best use of your capital at the
moment all right ready
we're at 2 000 likes right now we're
gonna give out 150 dollars we're the
winner for the massage gun by the way oh
who's the winner for the massage gun oh
logos
logos yeah
the massage gun yeah can we get a little
round of applause if you're sitting at
home right now i need a little round of
applause
let's get a little round of applause we
need to give people credit when they win
something we're about 150 with a bitcoin
right now but what i want is i want to
get to 2.5 k likes so on the count of
three everyone press like and then we
are going to give out 150 worth of
bitcoin right now live on the show ready
one
two three press the like button let's
get the 2.5 k likes we're gonna climb
the little mountain here to 2.5 k and
then we're gonna give out 150 worth of
bitcoin once we do that then we've got
kevin o'leary and jeremy alaire all
coming on to the show
i see you got your uh rich people water
today too is that
flex or something
no
i'm bringing it
jeremy who do we have
you know
are you picking someone
uh
who's gonna pick
by the way wait while we're waiting for
people to put uh put it in there uh what
i want is uh everyone in the chat while
they're pressing like button i want them
to leave us their twitter account handle
and i also want them to tell us what do
they think about inflation are they
worried about higher inflation or are
they not worried about higher inflation
so leave in the chat your twitter
account and also what is the uh uh
thoughts on inflation do you believe
that inflation is a problem or do you
not believe inflation is going to be a
problem moving forward we'll pick one
person we're giving away 100 150 100
don't don't take money from people 150
we give away a lot of money we do
the massage kind of blends together a
little bit the massage gun was pretty
good should we give away another 50 inch
screen tv at some point today yeah yeah
yeah
that's a good one do people like the 50
inch i feel like the 50s may be the best
thing that we've ever given away the
jordans were pretty good too but yeah
especially where was the per where did
the person live that we sent it to was
it like switzerland or something yeah it
was uh that's all the time all right
john you gotta you got somebody for uh
the 150 worth of bitcoin oh vancouver um
yeah
gabrielle
galani gabrielle
what'd they say
um i'm not worried because i'm 90
all right let's go i love that
all right what what questions do you
guys have by the way before uh kevin
o'leary and um jeremy lehrer come on
what questions do you guys have around
stable coins
are there specific things
um
is that is that what we're going to be
talking yeah
let me think
are the taxes for stablecoin yields are
they just based off your tax rate
okay what else
sas the audience
i i also uh i messed up and i gave the
wrong link earlier which is my fault to
uh kevin and jeremy that's why that's
why you're delaying time something they
can talk about what are different stable
coins backed by and the pros and cons of
each backing right so some are cash some
are how they're able to pay such a high
uh interest rate on some of them right
can i ask you to ask a question before
they come on john what news sites do you
go to when you wake up in the morning
what are the the news sites that you
check news sites
to learn about markets and uh i
subscribe to a ton of way too many uh
daily newsletters including the pump
newsletter then huddle up and then the
profile which is bi-weekly
and then um yeah i mean i just go to
bloomberg cnbc
um like actual sites and then i
obviously i have a feed of like a bunch
of new sites that i kind of uh just
browse through and try to check that
lines but yeah mainly like in the
morning newsletters
okay joe what do you check when you wake
up in the morning for news twitter
number one uh i think is the best source
of up-to-date kind of uh real-time news
uh a bunch of different newsletters it
feels like i have about 25 to 30 of them
in there now every morning uh try to
read as much as i can on those and then
website-wise like i think any of the
main sources when it comes to
traditional financial markets like if
you want to understand not only markets
but what's going on in the broader
economy wall street journal is good
bloomberg's good market watch like
seeking alpha any of those are pretty
good and then there's obviously a whole
host of kind of uh
digital or like bitcoin specific
websites that i think uh everyone should
be reading also wall street journal is
good too wall street journal
yeah um when one of the things that i
like about twitter is that it feels like
it's a filter like a bunch of stuff
bubbles up yeah and you kind of scroll
through quickly and then you can dig
into the websites but one of the things
i started to do on twitter that i think
is really
effective is i've actually turned on
notifications for a couple of
accounts that they just have news alerts
they don't tweet about anything else
it's kind of very high signal um you got
to pick the right ones because some of
them tweet too much but uh there's a
couple of accounts maybe i'll put them
in the chat at some point uh of a bunch
of uh
of uh accounts that give you really high
signal when you have notifications i did
uh walter bloomberg for a while but he
just tweets so much you can't have the
notifications on well i can't can we
talk about i think we're going to come
on the show for a source of it wait wait
can we talk about one thing real quick
can we talk about alec baldwin and the
gun
yeah i i i don't even know what happened
there it sounds like it was an accident
but kind of kind of sketchy i think
someone like handed them like a real gun
like a prop here's my understanding is
that uh they use real guns but they put
like a special bullet in it that has
like a yeah that's a blank but also i
think it uh uh is used specifically for
movies not just like a regular but i
think it's not like based on for movies
and somebody handed the gun to the
uh assistant producer or something who
then turned around and handed it to him
and he's just you know doing the movie
or whatever and he and he went to shoot
it and he shot a woman but it's not like
he shot another like actor actress he
shot like a like what was he testing it
and then he shot a second person so like
where they're like
i think it went through and then it also
like oh it hit someone else's director i
think yeah i mean it's there's a lot of
questions obviously it's very sad yeah i
i'm just shocked
uh it might not be getting nearly as
much attention as i thought it would be
getting the fact that like like somebody
yeah it seems like it's an accident
obviously right we just
you know got to uh well it's crazy that
one why are loaded guns on the set of a
movie
yeah well because because it's not
supposed to be a real bullet right it
was yeah about where are we going
come from yeah
i don't know right i mean there's a
bunch of questions all right i think we
have jeremy and kevin uh both here
let's see
give us one second to pull him up
jeremy how are you
hey i'm really good nice to see you nice
to see you as well kevin how are you
very good very good to see you again the
last time that i saw you you were
underwater now you're by a pond perfect
with your background there i'm also a
red goblin it looks like on that monitor
now you look great no problem jeremy
let's start with you in terms of give us
an update just for those that don't know
what is square
or i'm sorry what is circle and then
talk to us about the suite of products
that you guys have built
for various financial organizations to
use
yeah no no problem thank you yeah so uh
circle is a global financial technology
firm we've been operating in the crypto
and digital currency space for about
eight years since 2013
um have built a number of platforms and
products um you know today we operate
the largest uh regulated dollar digital
currency in the world aka dollar stable
coin which is
a usd coin or usdc which is about 33
billion in circulation and
accounts for a huge amount of the kind
of payments and settlement activity and
in blockchain transactions and payments
and defy and markets and and more and
more other types of activities we we
operate that we also provide
accounts for businesses
that want to be using
dollar digital currency and other crypto
as a core part of how they hold value
their treasury accounts as well as
payment utility through through payment
account functionality and we offer that
in a number of different ways but you
know we fundamentally offer it as a set
of apis and platforms that developers
can build on top of so whether you're a
startup that's building an nft market or
you're an established fintech that wants
to build in support for things like
stable coins and crypto into your own
products and services we offer that
set of apis that connect the existing
banking system the card networks the
bank networks things like that into uh
blockchain native uh digital currency
you know payments settlement and
treasury kind of services and i think
the last piece here that i would note in
in that area is um we have a treasury
product which is circle yield which
provides a way for businesses
specifically that want to allocate
uh dollars into usdc based lending
markets and generate high yield uh on on
their dollars at end usdc and then last
but not least we also operate one of the
largest fundraising platforms for
startups in the united states a product
called seed invest
which has grown quite a bit over the
past couple of years and we're excited
about continuing to help startups build
and grow their companies also
increasingly using more and more
kind of digital native approaches
got it and kevin last week when we
talked you talked a little bit about um
kind of using these stable coins to
generate yield like jeremy was just
talking about talk to us about what are
you guys actually doing with usdc and
how does that work
so i'm actually one of those business
accounts on
on circle
probably one of the earlier ones the
biggest problem most
let's call them institutional clients
have with usdc
is a compliance infrastructure that
locks into their systems so
you know my operating company i'm no
different than many millions of
businesses i have a compliance officer
because i'm an investor in all kinds of
financial services that are issuers and
so
i have to be able to mark to market uh
at four o'clock my compliance officer
has to see the positions and then send
that report off to the auditors who are
external that would sign those docs and
then report to the regulator and the
various geographies we operated
the the trouble with usdc or any
stablecoin for me just you know a year
ago was what platform can i plug into my
compliance department with is is it
going to be a bunch of decentralized
systems where i'm trying to convince my
auditor that this is compliant and i
wasn't able to i simply wasn't i could
not get them on board for using the
traditionally decentralized it was only
when i met
the team at circle and jeremy down at uh
in february in florida that we started
the dialogue with my own internal
compliance
and then eventually our auditors
and we're still in the in the startup
test phase we were actually you know
putting more and more dollar amounts in
to prove that this works and that you
can actually
uh do it on a daily basis you can open
up your accounts you can see your
positions you can see where you're on or
offside and uh right now
you know currently we're waiting for the
regulator to rule on uh usdc right i'm
trying to convince my own
compliance department that if you don't
want to treat it as money market then
treat it as a stock and put the same
uh weightings on it so
the good news is the potential for this
and the only reason i'm doing all this
work and that i'm involved with this is
i have a lot of cash sitting around now
because we took we drew down our our
commercial real estate portfolio
materially over the last year and a half
and our alternative for cash is 21 basis
points which doesn't even beat inflation
so we are looking for a solution like
this
and all the rest of this work is working
with compliance and regulators and
infrastructure and and getting this
thing on side and so
i'm i'm trying to
you know
drag my
compliance people and auditors out of
the dark into the light on this thing
and that's the good news but the even
more interesting news is how much of
this usdc has grown even since i started
i mean jeremy correct me if i'm wrong
but you're closing in on 30 billion
dollars here and that means there's a
lot of people doing the same thing i'm
doing
and we're not even
you know
we're not on side yet
and that means the potential
100 200 500 times bigger so that's where
we're at and uh i think the potential of
circle is huge i intend to become a
shareholder as soon as
uh the already disclosed back uh
despacks i'll be part of that pipe
and it's a great business and i think
it's a great solution and i think uh
we'll know more
in the in the months and years ahead on
how usdc grows into a payment system
jeremy talk to us about how big it
actually is right now
yeah so you so usdc let me just give you
some perspective
the beginning of 2020 right as the
pandemic was coming
usdc
was about you know 400 500 million
in circulation um we 10xed last year so
we grew from 400 million to 4 billion in
circulation so january 1st literally of
this year there were 4 billion usdc in
circulation
today we're nosing up against 33 billion
usdc in circulation so on track again
for roughly another 10x year of growth
this year and and we've seen over a
trillion dollars in transactions done
with usdc on public blockchains that's
not including all the volume that
happens on exchanges and things like
that so
um we really have seen
extraordinary growth uh you know in that
and and as as kevin was was saying you
know
um you know people are
are seeing that stable coins are an
extremely efficient way to settle
transactions around the world in the
same way we can exchange data on the
internet we can now exchange value
but it's also you know tapping into
these crypto capital markets and the
demand that exists for digital dollars
in these markets uh to obviously create
uh you know these kind of fixed income
type opportunities uh for people with
their stable coins
got it and when you guys start to think
about this obviously individuals is kind
of a no-brainer they can move quickly
they can determine hey i want a higher
yield
businesses seem to be um becoming
interested kevin you're doing a great
job kind of highlighting how your
business is thinking about it is this
something where we believe that every
corporation uh that's publicly traded um
you know large sovereign wells large uh
endowments foundations pension funds etc
they will all start to kind of get in
the game here as well uh or is this
something that is more so uh private
market companies and individuals and
that's where we think really kind of the
addressable market is
i mean i'll touch on part of that i'm
sure kevin's got great perspective on
this too uh which you know my view here
is that
the shift to
digital currency based payment and
treasury infrastructure which is
essentially to say
businesses that
connect to the internet
are going to increasingly not just with
their digital content and their software
and their information services they're
going to move their financial services
entirely to internet native
infrastructure that as that happens
every single internet savvy business in
the world
is going to store value in digital
currency is going to transact in digital
currency and is absolutely going to use
it as a cash management and a treasury
type infrastructure so we think the
total addressable market is every
internet connected business in the world
from startups to the biggest public
companies to more precisely though i
think um today we're seeing um you know
it's an interesting bifurcation when i
look at the the kinds of businesses that
are signing up for this in the early
access period which which kevin as noted
he was the very first customer we signed
up which was which was uh pretty cool
for this new new capability um
it's it is everything it's from startups
that are crypto native uh to
uh uh you know significant financial
institutions and public market companies
and others that are uh you know looking
at ways in which they can diversify some
of their treasury assets so it's both
institutional asset allocators but also
businesses mainline businesses that see
this as a way to augment what they do
with uh with dollars as well
kevin how are you thinking about sizing
it for your business um and then how do
you think other folks will think about
sizing uh this type of product uh if
they've got large pools of capital but
have kind of different structures from a
company's standpoint
i'd like to put a lot more into usdc but
i can't get my guys on board yet for
getting past
a mandate that we have up to a five
percent weighting in an equity
and they keep pointing the finger at me
saying let the regulator rule on this
thing
um
because there has been some discussion
in the market regarding stable coins and
i don't really think that all stable
coins are created equally um
but that's a different debate you know
there's a lot of of noise uh within the
crypto community about tether and other
situations you're well aware of that bob
i know that
um what i would love to have happen
frankly is that
the regulator and i'm not speaking for
jeremy i'm just saying what i'd like to
see happen is simply turn them into a
bank and i can use this as cash
alternative to uh what i would hold on
my
on my balance sheet because i'm not
making anything
on us dollars
i'm able to
to land this or
stake it if you wish whatever you want
to call it and make between 5.8 and 6.2
and in other cases if i wish to leave
and use other platforms even more but
my bigger problem and i i can speak to
this for many institutions that i
service in the more traditional equity
markets at indexing
we we need a plug-and-play solution so
that you know we can just say okay let's
open an account with circle uh let's put
in you know 20 of our cash holdings into
usdc let's use it as a payment system uh
let's stake it and get some yield on it
that's also in usdc issued i can convert
that back to fiat if i want
and i but i don't need anybody hassling
me i want i want the regulator to tell
me i'm okay with it
um
you know jeremy's
well able to deal with them and and
solve it i'm basically betting his horse
is going to win this race i guess
um and i'll be already set up and then i
can turn the spigot on and put some real
dough to work
uh and because it's it's small right now
as we're learning the systems and how it
works and how the reporting works but
the demand is is going to be huge and
i'm happy to be you know the first
business account i'm happy to be the
guinea pig whatever you want to call it
i just wish that we would get some clear
some clarity
um even if it doesn't even if the
regulator didn't have to deal with
bitcoin let's leave that alone let's
just deal with
stable coins let's get a ruling on that
let's get that worked out and let me get
to work on that because because there's
no
the train has left the station this
isn't going away let's get on with it
let's rule on it let's tell us what the
rules are let's get moving and and i'm
i'll i'll speak on behalf of sovereign
index and every fund we're all in the
same boat on this
i've got two of my my brothers here with
me uh or guy jeremy what we're gonna say
yeah i was just gonna i was gonna just
chime in on on on a point there which is
just to say um you know
as i think a lot of people know
we went out of our way to um you know to
to build usdc as a sort of electronic
stored value money transmission
technology that was sort of the
state of the art in terms of how
regulation applied to digital currency
firms that were doing this kind of
activity and that's how it's regulated
today
which is well understood uh it's like
your balance in a paypal account or or
stripe or square or others and i think
it's now really getting much much larger
and so you've got um you know the u.s
treasury department you've got the fed
you've got others sort of saying okay at
scale this actually um is is you know
ought to be kind of supervised as a
banking activity as a a special form of
banking activity stable coin uh banking
activity uh and we agree with that and
as you know we are preparing to file for
a national digital currency bank charter
um and we believe that is the right
approach to the kind of cash side of
this and then the other which is you
know
the the lending of stable coins either
can be a bank activity or it can be you
know structured as securities that are
purchased uh and and entered into uh
like other fixed income you know
products and that's also how we've
structured circle year it's it is
structured as a node purchased agreement
it is uh structured as a security and i
think that's an understandable
instrument uh for corporations that are
are are utilizing their their cash and
capital in in different ways
got it i've got two of my brothers here
what questions you guys got
hey kevin nice to see you again jeremy
nice to meet you uh jeremy so my
question would be people can earn on
usdc somewhere between six to seven
percent yield kind of depending on the
length of the term so my question would
be how are you able to do that versus
traditional lending instruments
yeah
it's a great question um and there's
actually a a good amount of info out
there on this on on on our website and
others so the the way to think about
this today
is
the the yields on usdc today are are
driven by demand in the crypto capital
markets uh and when i say crypto capital
markets i mean all of the different
investing trading lending other capital
market activity that's happening in
digital asset native infrastructure
whether that's on centralized exchanges
or or on d5
and within that arena there is a very
significant amount of dollar stable
point borrowing demand there are in in
principally from our perspective
very high quality institutional
borrowers and these range from
asset managers and other forms of asset
allocators to
hedge funds to
otc firms electronic markets firms you
know many many other institutional
market participants who want to borrow
dollar stable coins uh and put those to
work in these markets and they're
willing to pay
uh high interest rates for that and if
and they're willing to pay those high
interest rates because they're actually
generating significantly higher returns
and they can't go to jpmorgan chase or
they can't go to goldman sachs to borrow
stable coins uh and so there is this
intrinsic market demand that exists
and this has existed for years and years
and years i operated one of the largest
occ trading desks for a long time
and we borrowed
all the time and it was a really
powerful way to augment the working
capital that you had as a firm and so
that that's just going on it's going on
a much much larger level now there's
also a retail dimension to that which is
a lot of the borrowing against uh
protocols like ave and compound and
others
that's very much individuals
we exclusively lend on a wholesale basis
to institutional borrowers uh and i
think what also makes the the approach
that we're taking unique is a it's you
know certainly it's these high interest
rates that are that are you know
you know being paid but secondly
we actually over collateralize
every single every single loan so if
you're lending a million usdc through us
we're actually um
we're getting
1.25 million dollars in bitcoin
collateral against that and we're
constantly adjusting
the amount of btc based on intraday
price movements to ensure that we're
always in that 125 percent
collateralization so not only is it a uh
uh you know a a high yield it's also a
secured uh over collateralized uh you
know um you know you know asset as well
so i think that also makes it pretty
interesting
john what questions you got yeah nice to
meet you both hello kevin again um
so there's about 32 billion usdc in
circulation can you talk about what
actually backs that um and then going
forward will that change at all or be
consistent
yeah absolutely so um
just a high level of way to think about
this is
when we
launched usdc over three years ago we
did it
and have operated it under as i
described to you earlier the regulations
that exist by banking supervisors
throughout the united states so state
money transmission regulation so the
same regulation that applies to the
roughly 35 billion dollars that paypal
holds on its balances the however many
billion that square holds and so on same
regulations and those regulations have
require us to maintain a one-for-one
reserve
in dollar denominated assets
that are liquid such that we can always
provide that dollar uh in index you know
that that dollar uh in exchange for an
electronic money stored value instrument
so there is a regulatory framework
around this we've been examined audited
uh constantly report that both with the
banking regulators and our and our
public company owners and then we took
another step which was to basically
every month provide a report not not an
audit because you don't get audited uh
every month but a uh an attestation on
that in fact we're meeting those
obligations and it's on a one-for-one
basis with the digital currency units or
tokens outstanding so we've been doing
that for several years
the state laws
essentially bound you
to a very conservative underlying
set of permissible investments so you're
bound to a very very conservative base
of permissible investments and if you go
outside of that you're breaking the law
and so we've always been inside of that
um we've based on market feedback as
well as sort of i think where we think
regulators are going on this and this is
through what i'll kind of call
public sector signaling policy maker
preferences proposed regulations on
stable coins that we're seeing in the uk
and europe and singapore and other
places
we where this is going is
that
uh stable coin reserves if you want to
call it that uh should be in kind of
cash and cash equivalents exclusively
that is what we're seeing uh demanded
and that's what we've moved to uh so we
are a hundred percent in cash and cash
equivalents uh and we're committed to to
remain in that uh position uh until we
see regulations say otherwise i mean i
think this is gonna be a moving target
over time as these get to you know if
it's uh you know
half a trillion or trillion uh dollars
of value in these dollar digital
currencies um what is the underlying
kind of risk liquidity fiduciary model
that the federal reserve u.s treasury
and others will want to see that will
evolve obviously significantly over time
but today just to you know take a long
answer and make it very short it's 100
in cash and cash equivalents awesome
kevin when you think about usdc we've
talked a lot about the yield component
and thinking of it almost like an
investment asset that you can drive that
yield on is there a world where if you
could convince the partners or the
customers or your kind of business
transaction
participants to take usdc would you move
a material part or 100 of all of your
wires and kind of legacy banking
infrastructure payments to something
like usdc where you could do it more
instantaneous cheaper faster etc
yeah of course i would but i can't do
that now i mean let me explain what the
potential from my point of view as a
user of the product
one of the greatest frustrations that
i've articulated over the last couple of
years is what i do in
foreign markets on equities i i i have a
an index uh that involves 50
large-capped european stocks that
unfortunately or fortunately whatever
you want to say are three different
currencies in swiss francs and euros and
british pounds
one of the largest friction points for
me
in rebalancing these indices
is the fact that i have to go back and
forth through fx costs for friction of
fx trading
if if regulators could get behind a
digital payment system that would allow
me to own the securities in let's say
usdc at a price that's completely
transparent and liquid
i could avoid that friction in
perpetuity and it would be a much more
efficient way to do business to settle
in in a universal digital currency now i
know that sounds you know euphoric but
ultimately
we need to get there and and the u.s
dollar today is that currency it still
is you know many people speculate its
future but for hundreds of years it's
been the currency that people settle on
for all kinds of commodities and
services
it's very inefficient for what i'm doing
uh in these markets to to pay these
these these fx costs which vary by the
hour
and i see no value added and so
to me
let's get moving let's let's lead the
world in this in this process and this
efficiency i hate the idea that
our regulator would hold us back against
innovation when clearly it's needed and
on the baseline of usdc which you know
there are rules for money market funds
when you go to cash in your you know
brokerage account you get swept if you
wish into a money market account that
has rarely broken a buck and there are
rules
i see no reason we can't apply that kind
of regulatory environment to usdc
and you know have that settle that way
and of course i would put more into it
because i don't know where rates are
going to be once the regulator you know
rules on usdc they probably go down
you're not going to get six percent
anymore because there'll be a flood of
institutional demand but it's going to
be better than what i'm getting on u.s
cash is my assumption and in addition to
that could be far more efficient as a
payment system across a wide range of
different uses i mean the use cases here
are very broad and so
you know one way to look at it and i've
tried to convince in my own
conversations with regulators and most
of us have these ongoing dialogues in
our day-to-day business
to start thinking about usdc as software
really efficient software if you're
willing to invest in microsoft and i've
said this before in google why aren't
you investing in software that has such
promise
and that's basically what in my view
it's a personal opinion but when i
invest in circle as a business i'm
investing in software that provides
tremendous productivity and efficiency
in in a business i've been in for
decades financial services and the same
for the chain for all of the other
investments i'm making in
cryptocurrencies coins tokens and
you know blockchain itself it's it's
software to me and i think it's a
necessary investment and i hope that our
regulator our regulators see that we
should lead the world in developing
these protocols and these standards and
help us do so
jeremy one of the big questions that
people uh have in the chat is how does
circle make money and how does uh being
in cash and cash equivalents 100 until
you get that clarity from regulators how
does that affect your ability to make
money either positively or negatively
yeah so there are really a few buckets
of income for circle the first is that
usdc infrastructure so we're the
principal operator of that market
infrastructure there's as noted 32 going
on 33 billion it's in a very
conservative posture and the best way to
think about that is yes we generate
income from that and it's highly
interest rate sensitive right so like
other financial services cyclicals if
interest rates rise there's certainly
you know
more income potential
from that piece but we think of that as
really like um you know we're trying to
operate a market infrastructure that
everyone can can take advantage of the
second piece is through circle account
um we monetize in two ways one is people
who take advantage of our yield services
and who are lending usdc
and generating income uh
uh you know from those interest rates uh
and spread capture in that the second is
through what we call our transaction
services so
more and more businesses want to
integrate the existing financial rails
with things like usdc
and blockchain infrastructure so we have
a broad set of transaction services that
connect all those provide
platforms and apis people can build on
top of and we monetize that based on
essentially usage fees how much are you
using those transaction services how
much are you using
that the wallet infrastructure the
storage infrastructure the blockchain
infrastructure and our fiat rails so
that's another big category
of income so you've got the treasury
services the transaction services you
have usdc uh you know interest income
and then the third is basically
we have a take rate for every dollar of
capital that we raise for startups we've
helped startups raise hundreds of
millions of dollars that's growing
really nicely that's a really exciting
business uh our our investment platform
our seed capital platform and so we have
a take rate in that as well which is
another source of income for the company
got it so you got kind of a diversified
revenue stream here which makes a ton of
sense kevin when you think about uh
investing in circle in that pipe and i
know some of this thoughts to play out
uh over time um but equity i'm assuming
that you as an investor are thinking
about getting that kind of crypto
exposure like we talked about last week
that would be an equity investment which
doesn't go in the same bucket as let's
say your stable coin cash position
that's generating yield which may not go
in the same bucket as let's say your
minor position as well and so you're
kind of actually in some weird way not
thinking of crypto as one single bucket
but it's actually your stocks bonds
currencies and commodities you're
actually getting it infiltrated by these
companies and technologies across all of
those various buckets is that a fair way
to look at it
it is fair but there's also a personal
philosophy at play here you know when i
started my wine business i didn't own
any vineyards now i do i i i like to eat
my own cooking i like to own the
vertical i like to own the
infrastructure that supports the
business
so
why wouldn't i want to own a piece of
circle if i'm using usdc to me it just
makes intuitive sense and
as opposed to making uh you know five or
six percent interest on usdc as i as i
lend it out uh over a long period of
time if usdc becomes a standard i hope
it will i'll enjoy the capital gains
associated with owning part of the
infrastructure i i have been a stalwart
on this if you're going to get involved
in bitcoin that is simply one asset and
i am very diversified now into miners
their equities uh some of the coins they
own
certainly why wouldn't i want a piece of
circle if i'm going to be using usdc as
i said earlier but
you have to you have to make a binary
decision and there are many in the
financial services market that haven't
done the 180 that i have that have the
convinced they continue to try and
convince themselves that there's no
future
in in this in this software technology
there's no future in cryptocurrencies
there's no future in bitcoin there's
there's only regulatory hell ahead i
don't feel that way i i have a
completely different view of the world i
see the efficiency the productivity
potential and for me if i look at my
just you know the the time i spent
today at our 10 o'clock deal meeting uh
40
of that hour was just looking at the
at the crypto deals that that were being
shown we have a we're very fortunate to
have very very large deal flow
and it it's almost half of what we look
at now placing bets on all kinds of
different approaches
of some you know in recent times immune
holdings and wonderful and hopefully
circle soon and some of the coins that
we've talked the miners we've talked
about that i own now
this is this is going to be a 20
waiting in our operating company as an
and i've said this before and i'll say
it again
call it the 12th sect of the s p that's
what this is and in my world in my
compliant world i can own up to 20
of this sector and be compliant and
that's where i'm going end of this year
seven we'll see what happens next year
but pomp included in that 20 percent are
equities coins tokens chain developers
you name it you know it's just it's uh
it's the 12th sector of the s p but
nobody's called it that yet you come on
here and you tell us and flex so you got
a winery and then you tell us the 12th
sector i mean you are all time i mean
we're gonna have to bring you on like
once a week if you're gonna drop bombs
like that
uh jeremy last question for you and then
that will wrap up is uh talk to there's
a bunch of folks here who they either
run technology startups uh which means
that if they're in the private market
they probably raised a lot of capital
over the last 18 months or so they got
big balance sheets uh there's a lot of
small business owners uh that also have
driven and gotten a lot of cap on that
balance sheet how can they interact with
circle in terms of starting to get yield
or or use any of the products in terms
of like protecting that balance sheet or
participating in some way
yeah absolutely i mean look i i think um
it's pretty straightforward uh you can
you can sign up for a circle account
which is available for businesses it's
like opening a business bank account so
you you need to provide you know some
information so our compliance
organization can onboard you
and then you can sign up for the
treasury uh you know the treasury
account um offering which is the yield
service and that allows you to uh select
you know one month three months six
month twelve month uh tenors
and um it's weekly uh adjusting rates i
think i think you know a three month is
now uh you know
seven and a quarter or something like
that and you can um you know you can
elect to uh essentially wire funds into
usdc and then lend them through that
treasury account offering we have some
pretty exciting new product uh
capabilities on that front coming uh
through the remainder of this quarter
but that's the basics and so if you're a
startup and you want to utilize this
both from a working capital management
perspective or for the efficiencies of
usdc as a payment rail i think you know
a lot of people who have used usdc to
send and receive funds it's it's like
night and day compared to a wire or
traditional bank transfer it's it's sort
of what we've all become accustomed to
and using the internet is now
functioning for dollars and dollar
transactions on the internet and so i
think you know start using it with uh
partners with vendors with others and
and there are kind of network effects
that go along with that in terms of
bringing other people into this
ecosystem
awesome i appreciate both of you i i
this is me publicly saying i screwed up
and i sent you guys the wrong link so
this kevin was late last week but i sent
you guys the wrong link so everyone
knows that if someone's late it's
usually my fault because i did something
else but i appreciate both of you guys
coming on
thank you
thank you all right see you guys yeah
yeah bye-bye
do you either one of you have stable
coins and earn interest yup i do too
yeah yeah i don't have a ton but i don't
have a lot i'll be pretty open i use it
as i don't understand my bitcoin
i use it almost as like um
emergency
like cash fund i keep cash in there
because there's no point in um break
glass in case of emergency yeah well
there's no point in my mind of keeping
keeping cash in savings when they have
these vehicles that can give you almost
eight and a half percent on your money
um and what savings accounts are doing
point zero four percent four bases
it's a no-brainer for me um but you also
have to think of kind of the insurance
they have on stuff like this and um
how they're letting out your money right
people are saying that stocks have no
fundamentals so what's the problem with
the coins that have no fundamentals
[Music]
kevin loved it when you said that was my
fault
it was my fault by the way i also texted
her when i said now i own wineries is
one of the greatest flexes of all time
all right we are
at 2.9 k let's go on the count of three
everyone press the like button we're
gonna give out another hundred dollars
for the bitcoin that we got things we
got to go do
one two three smash the like button
right now but here's how we're gonna
give out the hundred dollars of bitcoin
ready john are you going to do it what i
want somebody to do is i want you to
leave your twitter account as always but
i also want
you to explain
do you own stablecoins
and what percentage of your portfolio
are the coins if you own any so
twitter account do you own stable coins
if so how much what's the percentage
jonah will pick one person
and we will give them a hundred dollars
with the bitcoin no no i have no more
bitcoin to give today we're all out of
uh of giving bitcoin at the moment
joe do you have any last thoughts for us
why john is waiting to uh pick the uh
coins no just in general life
uh i'm trying to think about what i'm
gonna do to get you back for the island
boys so can we
while we're waiting can we play that one
more time that was john look at john
john is still laughing now every time he
hears that was that not good yeah they
said as you can tell this show is live
they sent it to me this morning and i
got it now like or maybe overnight i saw
this morning and i was like oh man i
can't believe that they went ahead and
they did that
the uh the other thing too is i was
trying to get them to sing
but i guess they they ignored those
instructions
those guys don't seem like they're the
ones that take instructions well it's
all right hey big shout out to the best
business uh show was teaching everyone
about investing hey give the best
business show hey shout out to the best
business show and we're not joining the
union and i want to wish everyone good
luck and making about cash y'all keep
going man go down with the cash man hey
shout out to the business uh show and
yeah and do not join the union
[Music]
make it
the leggings i mean this is all the time
look at this right here joe and john
ready for the island boys
oh my god
[Laughter]
all right john you got a winner that to
me is amusing with that why are you
laughing
yeah
it's better than that one
[Laughter]
joe you kind of do look like that minus
the tats
what yeah that kind of does i got
someone all right sheldon pearson
shelton pearson you win 100
in bitcoin
congratulations
we appreciate all of you watching every
day i got three things for you first one
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel we are continuing and are not
going to stop until we build the biggest
show in the world with your help make
sure you are subscribed to the channel
subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe
to the channel second bestbusiness
show.com if you want any of the merch we
got trillionaire energy hoodies in there
we got the pay me in bitcoin shirts we
got the bitcoin 100k hats we have it all
literally right here all of it in the
store go to the store the bestbusiness
show.com if you got fresh gear you'll be
at the best business showdown i forgot
to mention i was in uh new jersey this
weekend wearing the pay me in bitcoin
merch and some guy came up to me he was
like yo i watched the show
did you did you try to recruit him to
the union uh he said he was in the room
yeah he said he was in the union until
he got busted by the island boys union's
not busted let's clear that up
like it's over all right i think the
union can break up from a meme video no
shot the union is over okay we'll see
about they killed it they buried it in
the ground they put the dirt back it's
over why don't we bring motion to
renegotiate contracts uh with the
audience here shortly and we'll see if
the union's busted we may not be here
tomorrow we may be on strike
the show might be better maybe
why not yeah i'll bring ranger i'll
bring ranger on and polina the show will
be viral ranger and paulina are both
part of the union yep no definitely not
ranger owes me money uh on top of this
part of the union
second is uh sofi.com pomp so tomorrow
we are doing the first diamond hands
club event which means that if you're
already in the diamond heads club which
is you opened an account you got to go
through sofi.com we won't know that
you're trying to get the diamonds club
so fi.com open an account once you open
an account get two thousand dollars in
the account you're in the diamond hands
club getting diamond heads club tomorrow
we are doing an event where we will go
on zoom private conversation we'll
answer questions we'll do a little
presentation it'll be this whole fun
thing diamond hands club no brainer if
you want to hang out with us on zoom you
got to be the diamond hands club there
will be future events there will be a
slack channel there'll be a whole bunch
of stuff go get in the diamond hands
club it literally cost you nothing all
you will do is get invested in the
market it's awesome no problem
anything else
i'm like a little tired today you are
yeah don't let lewis hear that yeah i'm
a little tired
it's hard work up here man you know you
guys like you guys just sit there and
chirp a little bit here and there you
get abused by the island boys
you actually two could be replacers for
the island boys maybe we need you guys
to create a little video go stand in a
place
on vacation
there you go like literally if you guys
recreated this video you'd go viral
probably when are we gonna get uh shelby
sushi her 1995 toyota camry she's
literally in all cabs day five of asking
for a 1995 toyota camry
how much are they i don't know used a
few thousand bucks
shelby 95.
let me see 19.95
shelby where do you live so we need to
show you where do you live real quick
where do you live
she bought a home
right
shelby where do you live with vtz
is shelby going to tell us where she
lives yeah there's like a five second
lag
why don't i listen i don't have lags my
brain works fast i'm [ __ ] automatic
shelby just tweet that pump he'll see it
no just tell us in the chat
where do you live so that we can know
zach sg john carries the show makes
sense
john sounds like he smoked 50 cigars
yeah john what is wrong with your voice
went to the giant game i was cheering
yeah you're good luck we're sending you
to the next game
all right
she'll come back i guess
shelby i don't know i i i don't know
shelby it was your time to shine
somebody said shelby's a car sales
show he's in car sales
all right she's not gonna do it all
right we're not gonna get it that's all
right we'll uh tomorrow shelby come back
tell us where you live we could i could
be convinced to buy a car
for somebody
95 uh toyota makes it a lot easier than
trying to buy a ferrari
all right we appreciate you guys
watching make sure you're subscribed to
the channel make sure that you like the
video see you guys tomorrow someone said
shelby lives with me send it here
[Music]
you